I told you a couple weeks ago that
Donald Trump took the fewest days the
smallest amount of time of any recent
president to get to fifty percent
disapproval right Donald Trump got to
fifty percent disapproval in only eight
days it took other presidents hundreds
of days even over a thousand days for
some reason president recent presidents
there's a growing problem that goes
beyond just approval for president
Donald Trump though and that's that
Americans increasingly think that he's
not a competent leader okay very
interesting new Quinnipiac poll it does
look at approval rating which is down
down now to 38% very very low for Donald
Trump but Quinnipiac asked another
interesting question which is do you
believe separately from whether you
approve of the job that he's doing do
you believe Donald Trump is a good
leader because you could think of Donald
Trump is a good leader who's doing
things you don't approve of right only
42 percent of Americans think that
Donald Trump is a good leader compared
to 55 percent who say he is not Donald
Trump's claim to fame it's supposedly
being a good leader remember running the
best businesses hiring the best people
by the way how funny is that
that campaign promised that he was going
to put the best people around him that
obviously didn't happen this represents
a major change in public opinion in
November after the election 56 percent
of Americans polled Quinnipiac same
polling agency same methodology that
Trump was a good leader that has dropped
nearly 20 points and if you consider
that Trump lost the popular vote but 56
percent of Americans in November still
thought he was a good leader you don't
get those numbers by accident clearly
there were people in that poll who
didn't vote for Trump but believed that
he did have leadership skills it's gone
downhill
as soon as Donald Trump started doing
stuff the abortive transition period the
embarrassing hires Americans
increasingly don't see him as a good
leader and that is really a crucial
aspect of the Trump cult of personality
what's amazing is that there's still
people who do think that he's a good
leader and that he's somehow an
intelligent person I mean yes we go back
to his business credentials I don't
think good leaders have their companies
go bankrupt six times yeah we know that
he inherited his fortune from his father
yes
all Trump does have talents I think he's
good at appealing to a crowd and I think
that's evidence because you know he was
able to get elected but he certainly is
not a good leader Trump attacking the
media also not playing well with
Americans the whole trying to turn the
people as he calls them against the
media so far it's working with some
committed trumpet but 90% of those
surveyed say they believe it is quote
very important or somewhat important
that journalist holds public officials
accountable and 50% disapprove of how
media has covered Trump at least people
overwhelmingly are still recognizing the
importance of critical media my reaction
to this polling is well yeah but if I'm
not trying to play the if only game
right we could do the if only FBI
director James Comey hadn't written that
letter if only people had realized that
Donald Trump is not a good leader during
the campaign we today have a president
who cannot speak at length about any
issue cannot put sentences together with
anything but the simplest structure has
no attention span doesn't read can't
control himself to avoid reacting
childless trial childishly to whatever
is on the TV in front of him the correct
assessment of Trump is that he is not a
good leader that he can't be trusted and
that he doesn't know anything but to
jump on what you're saying Pat I
actually am more disturbed by the fact
that 42% do think he's a good leader
what are they thinking especially
because he's been in the public eye for
decades now I mean people know this
they've seen so many interviews with him
yeah and this hasn't changed since he's
become president and we know that from
his recent press conference that was a
disaster
an hour long of just you know a mess of
words total mess gong show here's what I
want you to tell me about on Twitter I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the shows on
Twitter at David Pakman show
when will we will we or aunt and if you
believe we will when will we see Donald
Trump's approval rating dip into the 20s
do you think that will happen and how
soon let me know I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman